if you expect to achieve your goals if
you expect to reach your potential if
you expect to have your dreams come true
what about just explained to you is
mission critical you must become a
master at visualization now for those of
you that are like what the heck is she
talking about I did not sign up for some
sort of meditation woo spiritual thing
here don't worry this is Mel Robbins
there's always science and research
involved in everything that I talk about
so visualization is a extraordinarily
powerful skill and you may have heard of
the law of attraction you may have heard
of the word visualization you may have
heard of the word manifesting I call it
seeing signs so I'm a master at seeing
positive signs I am a master of creating
coincidences I have the world's most
incredible luck you want to know why
because I understand the science and the
skill of visualization I know that your
brain it is a gigantic detective machine
your brain is a filter your brain is
constantly looking for evidence and
that's good news it's good news when you
know how to use it to your advantage
let me explain so your brain has a
system in it here's the technical term
it's called the reticular activating
system it is a network of neurons all up
in here and what is the job of the
reticular activating system it is a
filter system it's basically a system
that allows certain information in your
brain
it blocks out other information and
guess who programmed that filter you did
and so did the people from your past and
so if you constantly feel like you're
unlovable guess what your reticular
activating system is going through the
day and it is going to point out every
single piece of evidence that confirms
that negative belief that you have if
your goal is to improve your self-worth
I want you to visualize what your life
looks like and how you're going to feel
about yourself when your self-worth has
improved here's how you're going to do
it so there's two things that you have
to do when it comes to visualization you
have to close your eyes truly I know it
sounds stupid but I want you to close
your eyes and I want you to in your mind
have a specific picture of what it looks
like in your life when your self-worth
has improved you're gonna see yourself
speaking up at work
you're gonna see yourself talking more
about your business you're gonna see
yourself leaving bad relationships
you're gonna see yourself defining
boundaries you're gonna see yourself
going to the gym you're gonna see
yourself taking care of yourself and
when you start to visualize the image of
that I want you to consciously this is
step to consciously think of the
positive emotions that you're gonna feel
I'm gonna feel happy I'm gonna feel
proud I'm gonna stand taller I'm going
to be so grateful that I made this
change marrying the the specific picture
oh there I am there I am I'm I'm it I'm
at work and I'm raising my hand
amazing I'm sharing my tea there I am
I'm gay
promotion there I am asking for a raise
there I am I've just signed up another
customer to my business there I am I've
gone back to school I feel so good about
myself when you do that here's what's
actually happening in your brain this is
the cool science part you are training
your brain to have a totally different
filter you see your brain my brain it
doesn't know the difference between
something that actually happened to you
like the f you got in your test in tenth
grade and the things you imagine that
are happening to you let me say that
again your brain doesn't know the
difference between the bad things that
actually happen to you the real memories
that you have and an imagined memory
that you're creating your brain will
experience you visualizing going to the
gym you visualizing how happy you feel
when you do you visualizing asking for
that raise and getting it and how proud
you're going to feel your brain when you
visualize in the way that I'm teaching
you to it it encodes it as a real memory
and that's important because when you
encode it as a real memory
it changes the filter system that
reticular activating system and here's
what we know based on research the more
you visualize things number one the
greater your confidence is going to be
the greater security you're gonna have
about it and here's the really cool
thing the more you do this with your
goals you wake up every day and you just
visualize for it takes 30 freaking
seconds for crying out loud you
visualize having a great day at school
you visualize curing your panic
how proud you're going to be what
studies suggest and have proven is that
simply visualizing yourself doing things
actually develops the skill and helps
you improve the skills just as if you
were actually doing it
the problem with passion is that you and
I have bought into this massive fantasy
world where we think that passion is a
person or a place or a thing that
somehow like a needle in a stay hat and
a needle in a haystack that you are
somehow just going to stumble into the
thing and you're gonna find that one
person are you gonna find that one thing
that you're meant to do or you're gonna
find that career and honestly we got to
change the way that you think about
passion and purpose before you will
actually be able to bring it into your
life because the truth is passion isn't
in a person it isn't in a place and it
isn't in a thing it's something inside
of you
and when you flip the definition of what
passion is and when you actually
understand what you're looking for when
you say I want to discover my passion
then you'll be able to create more of it
in your life I started thinking about
luck because there are for a long time
in my life I started to think that luck
was for other people that luck was just
one of those things that if you were
lucky enough to be born with luck you
won the lottery you got the job you
wanted your family got along
the truth is there's a tremendous amount
of science behind luck that luck is
something that you can make for yourself
that you can become luckier based on the
things that you do and the things that
you think about and one of the things
about lucky people is a lot of lucky
people make their luck because they have
trained themselves to think
optimistically and one small trick that
you can use in your life that is free
you can do it today is when you go to
bed tonight before you go to sleep I
want you to write down one thing that
happened today that was good
that's it every night before you go to
bed I want you to write down one thing
that happened today that's good in fact
let's do it right now in the comments go
to the comments and tell me one thing
that has happened today that you can
think of that's good just one thing
maybe you got up on time maybe you
didn't have traffic today on the way to
work maybe you haven't fought with your
kids this morning maybe you got to the
gym maybe you woke up and for the first
hour of the day you didn't make yourself
wrong all of those things while they're
really little don't dismiss them because
those are things that are good and the
reason why I want you to start a
practice where every night before you go
to bed or if you don't want to do it at
night do it in the morning every night
before you go to bed write down one
thing that happened today that was good
the reason why you're doing this is you
are training yourself to start to spot
the good believe it or not training
yourself to start to look for the good
in your life fundamentally trains your
mind away from looking at
negative so that you start seeing this
thing that's positive about your life
versus that thing that's negative about
your life you're never ever ever ever
going to feel like doing the things you
need to do in order to have what you
want you're always going to need to push
yourself you're always going to need to
parent yourself so what is the net
advice on this what what is the bottom
line the bottom line is no one's coming
no one no one's coming to push you no
one's coming to tell you to turn the TV
off no one's coming to tell you to get
out the door and exercise nobody's
coming to tell you to apply for that job
that you've always dreamt about nobody's
coming to write the business plan for
you it's up to you and because you're
only ever gonna do the things that you
feel like doing right now or that feel
good right now unless you understand
that you've got to parent yourself you
got to push yourself you're not gonna
make your dreams come true
you're just not we're not wired that way
you weren't born that way your work that
way when you're going up and you're
certainly not that way as an adult and
there's a tremendous amount of
liberation that comes when you accept
the fact that you're always going to
need to give yourself a push the truth
is if you want control in your life if
you want to make things happen you have
to be able to expect that you're gonna
get a no and do it anyway so what do I
mean when I say if you want control
expect an oh well there's a couple
things that I mean by it number one if
you're somebody that gets paralyzed
because you want things to be perfect
perfectionism is a way that most of us
try to handle or mitigate or make sure
that we don't hear no we assume that if
we're perfect everything's gonna go okay
and so we spend all of our energy
thinking about our dating profile or
thinking about the business plan or
thinking about how to make things
perfect
and the reason why we do that is we're
terrified to hear now we're terrified to
put something out there that's not
perfect because if it's not perfect you
might get an O one of the better ways to
handle this is to actually expect an O
you know I saw the most incredible quote
by our friend Faustina over in Australia
she's very famous VJ and friend of ours
from Australia and she put out the most
amazing quote and I'm gonna get it
totally wrong but it's something like
this you have to be yourself because how
else are the people who are looking for
you gotta find you and I think
particularly when it comes to dating
what we tend to do is we are so afraid
of being rejected by anybody out there
that we try to be somebody that we're
not that we put out a fake improved or
what we think is improved version of
ourselves in order to not hear no and
most of us pretend to be somebody that
we're not when we fear rejection when we
believe that how we are who we are isn't
good enough and so that's why it's so
important for you to understand that you
have to be willing to hear a no you have
to be willing to hear a no from the
wrong people so that the people that are
looking for you can find you so that the
people who want to be part of your
business can be part of your business if
you're putting a fake person out there
or a pretend perfect person out there
because you think that's gonna that's
gonna save you from rejection
you're actually screwing yourself over
you're not a procrastinator you have a
habit of procrastinating big difference
because if it's a habit I can teach you
to use science to break it you see all
habits have three parts there's a
trigger and in the case of
procrastination the triggers always
stress then there's a pattern you repeat
and in the case of procrastination it is
to avoid doing something and then
there's a reward you get a little stress
relief the only way to break a habit you
guys is not to deal with the triggers
you're never gonna get rid of the stress
in your life
but you can 100% change your pattern of
avoiding work so next time that you're
in a situation where you feel yourself
hesitate you spent way too much time
checking out the highlights from last
night's scores what you're gonna do is
you're gonna go up I must be stressed
out about something acknowledge the
stress then go 5 4 3 2 1 I want you to
count to yourself because I want you to
interrupt the habit that's stored here
and I want you to awaken your prefrontal
cortex then I want you to just work just
for five minutes the reason why I want
you to only work for five minutes is
because your problem isn't working it's
the habit of avoiding I just need you to
start and here's the other cool thing we
know based on research that if we can
get you to start 80% of you are going to
keep going do it anyway is a mindset
trick that you can use when you start to
feel excuses rolling up it works a lot
like the five-second rule so you have
said to yourself okay I'm gonna talk to
my boss today about that thing that I've
been avoiding talking to them about or
maybe you've said something like I'm
gonna go to the gym today or tomorrow
whatever and then the moment comes where
you've got to have that conversation
where the moment comes where it's time
to pack up your bag and leave your desk
and go to the gym and what always
happens you don't feel like it I bet
there are plenty of you watching that
have made a commitment that yeah I'm not
gonna have a drink today and then guess
what happens when you get home you don't
feel like not drinking you feel like
having a drink and so here's what do it
anyway has done for me the idea that I
just do it anyway has pushed me to
realize and to recognize that there are
a lot of moments where there are things
in my life that I really want to do I
need to do I should do but when the
moment comes I don't feel like it and so
I pull out this idea of you know what
I'm just gonna do it anyway it's raining
outside I said I would go for a short
run I don't feel like it I'm gonna do it
anyway it's six o'clock in the morning
I'm tired it's cold I laid out my yoga
clothes but now I don't feel like it
what do I do I do it anyway when you
start to say to yourself I'm gonna do it
anyway what happens is something really
cool you acknowledge that there are
feelings that you have that are trying
to swoop in and hijack you you
acknowledge them and you basically say
guess what I'm gonna do it anyway the
one person that is diminishing your
ability to make these dreams of reality
is you because when you state your dream
this is what happens you state it and
then all of a sudden you're present to
how far away you are from it and when
you see the distance between where you
are and where you want to go the
direction that your dream requires you
to walk in you're gonna get present to
the gap and that scares us that's where
fear comes into play and you start to
think of all the reasons why you know
survey to start to think of all the
reasons why you can't do it all that you
have to do in order to start to pursue
your dreams is take small actions every
day that align your life in that
direction so what does that mean if you
want to play guitar professionally it
means that you start playing guitar more
it means that you sign up for open mic
nights it means that you go back to
classic if that's something that
interests you you see your dreams will
happen either because of you or in spite
of you they don't happen because of
other people they happen because of you
and what you do the second you have the
bravery to state that dream now are you
going to create it or are you going to
diminish it in your mind here's your new
definition of passion passion is simply
energy that's all that it is okay
passion is what you feel when you are
energized and excited about what you're
doing okay I want you to think about
that for a minute I want you to think
about a moment in time when you felt
incredibly passionate about something
okay and why don't you in the comments
tell me where are you watching from and
tell me about a moment in time when you
felt incredibly passionate about what
you were doing about where you were
about the people that you are with
describe that moment for me because when
you start to really investigate passion
as energy this is what you're going to
discover those moments when you are
super passionate like I'm sure my kids
would write down when they're doing
community theater with all their friends
I would write down whatever I'm doing
any kind of creative project with my
team I'm incredibly energized whenever
I'm doing group exercise stuff climbing
a mountain doing a 5k race doing some
sort of walkathon I'm incredibly
energized by that whenever I'm doing
some sort of creative project incredibly
energized by that whenever I'm working
with our video team in
credibly energized by that whenever I am
coaching someone or giving advice I am
incredibly energized by that and so what
I want you to understand is that if you
look back on your life you have had
moments where you have felt passion I'm
being very deliberate and how I'm
talking this morning on coffee talk
because passion is a huge topic for so
many of you and you've been so focused
on trying to figure out what job is
gonna make me passionate what job is my
passion what is my purpose on the earth
I'm gonna tell you what your purpose on
earth is right now your purpose on earth
is to figure out how to align your life
so that you feel more energized and
excited by it that's it and it begins
with you following the energy and
following your natural enthusiasm you're
not gonna think your way to passion you
can't think your way to finding
something that you feel in your heart it
doesn't work that way you got to feel
your way into it it's inside of you do
you understand there's no passion out
there somewhere the passion is in here
and so what you have to do first is
you've got to stop thinking that you're
gonna find it somewhere and you've got
to realize that passion is about
unlocking something that's already in
you you or in your home and then we go
to kindergarten and then you go to first
grade and then you go to second grade
and then you go to third grade and then
you're gonna fourth grade and then you
go to fifth grade and then you go to
middle school and then you go to high
school and then there's the pressure to
go to college or to a tech school or to
do something else and then you get your
job and then you're in your job and then
you meet somebody and then you get
married and then you're supposed to buy
the house and then you're supposed to
have the kids and maybe you get the dog
before the kids are after the kids but
then you have a second kid and then you
have the 0.5 kid because it's both of us
do 2.5 kids and then we get and then we
get the the home equity line and then we
put the kitchen addition on and then we
I mean it's like our entire lives are
set out in this linear progression as
people chase
the dream and particularly for those of
us who are triggered by the fear of
losing control it's only natural to
anchor your feeling of being in control
to chasing the next thing and so not
only are we all socialized to believe
that we're supposed to climb this ladder
we're supposed to do things in a linear
progression we're supposed to get to the
next thing we've also been marketed to
by society that will be happier if we
have a new car we'll be happier if we
have a better dishwasher we'll be
happier if we have the skin lotion
that's got the almond scent and we are
also psychologically anchoring our sense
of control and our sense of happiness on
achieving those things and what you're
experiencing is no different than what
millions and millions and millions of us
experience and that's that emptiness
that you feel when you buy the lotion
that smells like almond butter and it
doesn't make you happy or you get the
promotion and you have an extra hundred
bucks in your paycheck after taxes and
it means you can buy the 14 dollar
Chardonnay not the ten dollar shorten
Chardonnay and it doesn't make you happy
and the reason why is the I'll be happy
when life the chase the carrot life the
get to the next thing life
that form of happiness requires you to
be driving let's use the car analogy
again to be going 60 miles an hour at
all times and Happiness is achieved
through a different formula it happens
when you're sitting at the light and
you're idle when you're in the moment
doing things that make you happy and
that's being with people that you care
about it's engaging in experiences that
make you happy and it's just working on
things that are important to you if you
want some more affirmations with Edie
mine let check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there so there's this Governor on our
lives and it is a governor and it's a
it's your identity it's this internal
it's what you think you're worth it's
what you think you deserve